I'm told a good friend of ours has a  request please welcome mr. Deon Cole  let's get him out of here  [Applause]  welcome Deon welcome to the historic  Apollo Theater yes thanks cone  appreciate that brother Deon my brother  what can I do for you it's very simple  calling it I want to make history here  tonight I want to be the very first  black comic boo by all-white audience at  the that would be incredible the first  black comic to be booed by an old white  audience at the Apollo you want to see  him do it what do you call a astronaut  putting on his boots shoot I'm at the  Apollo  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  what do you call a sleeping bull a  bulldozer  [Applause]  was Green and walks through all's Casper  the Petco  [Applause]  you